todo lo que vamos a hablar hoy es acerca
la inflación y la deflación pero antes
de tocar este tema creo que es muy
importante obtener una comprensión del
nivel microeconómico en cuanto a por qué
los precios aumentan o disminuyen y
vamos a hacerlo en un ejemplo digamos
que voy a comenzar un negocio y me voy
me pregunto cuándo aumentan o disminuyen
los precios de este negocio
digamos que quiero empezar una fábrica
de cupcakes
cupcakes una fábrica de cupcakes y
durante el proceso de este vídeo aunque
no es la intención de esta lista de
reproducción la intención de esta lista
es que puedas ir con tu profesor de
economía y decir ahora mina en esta
situación vamos a no tener inflación por
las siguientes razones pero bueno en el
proceso quizás vayamos a aprender un
poco sobre contaduría y cómo empezar una
fábrica de cupcakes digamos que entonces
quiero empezar esta fábrica la cual me
cuesta un millón de dólares de dólares
para construir
y digamos que solo la operación de la
fábrica cuesta 500 mil dólares al año
gay
esto cada año
aunque esto es digamos para pagar la
cuenta de la electricidad los
trabajadores que hacen los pastelillos
los contadores todos los demás tengo que
pagarle a la gente que limpie en el
lugar en fin digamos que la economía de
los pastelitos mismos de los cupcakes el
costo de cada uno es de un dólar
un dólar permítanme escribir esto en
rojo
bueno quizás después así que el costo
por unidad es de 1 dólar
por cada cupcake y de dónde viene todo
ese costo bueno para este ejemplo vamos
a suponer que tengo una fábrica
completamente automatizada y robótica
y digamos que hay muy poquito trabajo en
mi fábrica así que realmente es el costo
de los ingredientes no sé la crema el
azúcar la mantequilla en los papeles con
los que se envuelven los cupcakes en fin
la electricidad para correr los robots y
bueno todo todo el mantenimiento de los
robots para hacer la fábrica sale
entonces cual digamos que bien pensemos
que yo cobro por cada cupcake dos
dólares vamos a suponer eso
entonces este sólo es un ejercicio en el
cual pensar por supuesto
otra cosa mi millón de dólares de la
fábrica puede producir un millón de
cupcakes al año aunque entonces esto es
nuestra producción un millón de cupcakes
al año ok entonces
como yo soy un hombre de negocios no voy
a invertir un millón de dólares para
construir sin saber qué es lo que va a
ocurrir en el futuro entonces vamos a
plantear varios escenarios digamos vamos
a llamar a este primer escenario el
optimista ok y eso es que yo vendo
exactamente un millón de cupcakes así
que mi fábrica produce un millón de
cupcakes y vendo un millón de cupcakes
cuando un millón de cupcakes
voy a tomar un espacio acá porque este
es un detalle que quiero traer a flote a
menudo estoy al tope ok puedo producir
un millón de cupcakes en este escenario
y quiere decir que estamos utilizando el
100% cuánto producimos relativo con qué
tanto podemos producir 100% así que si
bien de un millón de cupcakes cuál sería
mis ingresos
voy a entrarle un poquito a detalles de
contaduría déjenme escribir
los ingresos en verde
y lo escribiría en negro perdón pero mi
fondo es negro así que lo voy a hacer en
verde
los rojos significan que son números
negativos así que bueno vamos a dejarlas
y cuál sería mis ingresos bueno si
viendo un millón de cupcakes y este es
mi escenario optimista recuerden lo
vamos a decir que soy capaz de venderlos
todos a dos dólares obviamente este es
discutible verdad que que tanto debe
costar un cupcake así que tendríamos dos
millones de dólares al año
ahora cuál es el costo de costo de venta
el costo de venta y lo voy a escribir de
esta forma y esto así es como lo van a
ver en las declaraciones de ingreso de
algunas de algunas compañías de verdad
también lo pueden ver como costos de
bienes o costos variables en fin tienen
varios nombres de hecho el costo de
bienes o el costo de servicios es lo que
verán más a menudo en ocasiones así que
si tengo un millón de pastel y de
pastelillos digamos tengo un millón de
cupcakes
cuál es mi costo por por cupcake esto es
de un dólar por cupcake así que tengo un
millón de dólares al año
y cuál es mi ganancia vendiendo los
cupcakes bueno pues simplemente hay que
tener cuánto cuestan todos los gastos
generales y lo que vamos a hacer es una
resta entre los ingresos y los costos de
venta y este término se le llama la
ganancia bruta
ganancia bruta ok y eso es eso es
esencialmente cuánto dinero ganó por los
cupcakes así que cuánto me cuesta hacer
estos cupcakes déjenme poner una línea
aquí y vamos a hacer la resta así que la
ganancia bruta estoy ganando al final un
millón de dólares verdad yo no diría ese
estupendo estamos haciendo un millón de
dólares en la fábrica de cakes en este
escenario pero no lo hemos terminado
porque esto es sólo el dinero directo de
las ventas de los cupcakes tengo todos
estos gastos generales y a menudo en un
ejercicio digamos de este tipo se le
llaman ventas generales o
administrativos costos generales de
operativo en fin yo le voy a llamar
costo general y esto también lo va a
poner en rojo
esto es el anterior estaba en rojo
también y este vamos a escribirlo en
rojo también
entonces esto cuesta 500 mil dólares
anuales digamos así que cuando estoy
ganando en el negocio cuánto será a esto
se le llama ahora si las ganancias
operativas cuando estoy ganando por
operar el negocio pues simplemente no no
voy a discutir todos los detalles de un
estado de resultados de un estado de
cuentas pero bueno esto como nota parte
todo debajo de la línea cubre cosas que
no estén relacionadas ok serían costos
relacionados con el financiamiento de la
empresa no se puede haber muchas cosas
yo sí pido un préstamo estamos
suponiendo estamos suponiendo en este
punto un mundo ideal en donde no hay
digamos impuestos entonces mis ganancias
operativas son son realmente ganancias
porque sólo tengo que hacer la resta
entre la ganancia bruta
los costos en el gasto general y
entonces eso nos quedan 500 mil dólares
anuales
y eso es bastante bueno o sea yo tenía
un millón de dólares invertidos entonces
una inversión de un millón me da 500 mil
dólares de ganancia así que gane la
mitad de lo que había invertido y estoy
ganando muchísimo cada año en este
escenario esto es un beneficio del 50
por ciento lo cual es genial si yo te
dijera oye tengo una inversión por
supuesto que te firmo el cheque para
ganar el 50 por ciento anual pero por
supuesto ese es un escenario optimista y
hay una multitud de escenarios porque
puedes seguir ajustando cuánto vende es
a qué precio lo vendes es un ejercicio
bastante divertido para hacer en excel y
que podrías hacerlo ahora ahora me voy a
preocupar de otro caso por ahora qué es
lo que tengo que hacer para asegurarme
que no pierda es decir vámonos a un
escenario pesimista aunque vamos a
hacerlo ahora al revés
vamos a hacer un análisis de punto de
equilibrio y créanme esto eventualmente
nos va a llevar a la posición de
determinar si hay inflación o deflación
en esta economía ok y creo que mientras
podemos aprender cosas interesantes
acerca de empezar un negocio así que
digamos que quiero saber qué qué pasa
con esta para que tengo que debe ocurrir
para que tenga una una ganancia de
operaciones nulas o sea que tenga cero
entonces los costos generales
esto digamos esto es fijo no no no puedo
hacer nada y si yo quiero tener una
fábrica de cupcakes eso me va a costar
fijo 500.000 y lo voy a poner en
negativo porque lo va a restar verdad
así que cuál cuál debe ser las ganancias
las ganancias brutas así que para que
esto nos dé 0 deben ser exactamente
500.000
ahora podemos ya pensar en una serie de
posibilidades en las que yo tenga una
ganancia bruta de 500 mil verdad por
ejemplo si yo vendiera como podemos
obtener 500 mil digamos que estamos
vendiendo no sé que eso lo vamos a
vender 500 mil cupcakes
ok
estoy esto debería funcionar así que
nuestros nuestros ingresos son 500.000 y
digamos que estoy vendiendo cada uno a
dos dólares verdad entonces tendríamos
un millón de ingresos por año por
supuesto ahora el costo de mis cupcakes
ok el costo de venta esto lo voy a poner
en rojo para ser consistente verdad cuál
es el costo de venta bueno dijimos que
era un dólar por cupcake verdad así que
tendríamos 500 mil cupcakes por un dólar
verdad y por supuesto sería muy tonto
vender cupcakes a menos de un dólar
verdad por supuesto estaríamos casi
regalando cheques a nuestros comedores
de cupcakes pero bueno en cualquier caso
mis ingresos serían de un millón mis
costos de venta de 500 mil que se
equivalen con los gastos generales y
entonces tendría una ganancia de
operaciones no la verdad
cero
perfecto entonces al menos no perdería
dinero esto es interesante porque eso me
dice que si yo cobro dos dólares por
cada cupcake tengo que vender al menos
500 mil cupcakes para poder empezar a
ganar dinero así que tú puedes decir ok
bueno eso no sería racional vender menos
de 500 mil cupcakes de lo contrario no
funcionaría el negocio y bueno veremos
en vídeos futuros que actualmente hay
ciertas situaciones que exploran esas
esos casos en donde también empiezan a
bajar los precios para competir y
empiezan a hacer cosas bastante
irracionales en fin ya se me ha acabado
el tiempo para este vídeo nos vemos en
el próximo y vamos a ver qué sucede al
abrir la fábrica